[Music]
gotta have a hobby
gotta do something else can't work all
day long
beautiful day in the park in boston this
is the commons it's lovely
fall day you know swans in the park and
all that
i thought it'd be a great time to answer
some questions i've been you know
falling a little behind on ask mr
wonderful but there's one
constant theme i get all the time this
one's from millie but it's the same
thing
do you think there are common successful
attributes
in people and i guess what she's asking
is can you find a string of things that
that is the same for people that are
successful
do they all do the same thing well of
course they don't all do the same thing
but i have found over time
in working with lots of ceos and that's
business but also
artists musicians photographers
you know those kinds of watch collectors
there are some elements of their lives
that i find are consistent i want to
share them with you today
first of all this this concept of
priorities
now i learned this from you know a woman
ceo years ago
to actually carry with you all the time
and i have it right here
if i don't have my big notebook i carry
a small one with me
paper just paper and
what i've got in here are notes and i
carry a pen with me all the time
i love to collect pens this is a new
egyptian mo blanc
when i know i when somebody hits me
wherever i am
i remember to write it down and the
reason i do that is i build a priority
set
that i put down each night and out of
all the priorities of the day i carry
three
into the next day because you can even
see here's a day
you can see that a bunch of stuff has
been a bunch of priorities there but
i've
i basically done them i got them done
but this idea of um
prioritizing ends up being a really big
deal so that's attribute number one
politicians teachers generals ceos
they build a data set in their heads of
things they've got to get done
and they don't do anything else until
they've achieved those for me it's
sticking out on the mirror each night
i've talked about this countless times
and i don't do anything else to get
those three done and they're built from
the list that i generate during the day
so
definitely for all successful people
regardless of what their discipline is
that idea of priority really matters
number two you may find this interesting
but it's
it's looking good and feeling good you
know i don't go out into the sun
and i've talked about them before tees
hanley skin creams and things that are
really healthy for you
particularly from espf at least spf 20.
you know i got the chrome dome i got to
make sure it's looking good all the time
before i came out here i put some
moisturizer on
so i dip into my kit my peach handling
kit i find my morning application
it's all right on here it says
moisturizer with spf 20.
exactly what i need protect
the dome don't let it burn around the
nose and the eyes
that easy and what i like about them is
they send me a kit it's got an
instruction card in it
i don't have to think it through
basically each
vial or bottle or you know tube tells me
exactly what it's for it's
really easy to implement it doesn't have
any smelly perfumes
which i hate so i constantly using it
you know because they're sponsoring this
this
youtube video today i obviously ask them
for a deal
they're going to include a free toiletry
bag if you go to the first link in the
description you can get
it there check that out tiege hanley uh
i endorse it because i use it i don't
endorse products i don't use
but hey you got to have the dome looking
good all the time and
skin you've got to keep it moisturized
and you kind of keep it out of the sun
i don't care who you are that really
matters
now something else that's really
important is
and i can't stress this enough and the
more i experience this with people
the more i believe it to be true you
have to have another passion
besides the one that is your discipline
in other words
if you're a teacher you have to do
something else but that's not teaching
if you're a ceo and you're just driven
by business which you know entrepreneurs
really are
you've got to find a passion that's
really important
and i don't care whether it's music or
whether it's
playing an instrument or it's collecting
watches i love to do that too
you can have multiple passions i you
know i love pens i love watches love
guitars
i love photography they distract me
from the intensity of my core
discipline which is business i'm an
investor you know i'm
an entrepreneur i invest in companies i
try and help them work
and that gives me financial freedom
which of course is very important but
i gotta do something else i i have to
and
you know that i find more and more is a
really big deal with successful people
they're very disciplined in what they do
well
in their main focus in life yes
but they've also got other passion it
can be a single passion or it can be
multiple
and that ying and yang which i've spoken
of so many times
is so important there's no question
about that
you know when i really think through uh
what it what has helped me so much and
and those that i really follow and
that i admire you know everybody's got a
mentor
and there's always somebody that's more
successful than you and you can learn
from them
i don't care how successful you are
there's always somebody that's better
and you should realize that in your life
and that's okay there's always something
to learn
but those people to me look good they
feel good they have priorities
and they make sure that they attempt
some kind of yin and yang i didn't say
balance because if you're an
entrepreneur there's no balance
you're going to be working 25 hours a
day eight days a week
i mean that's just the way it is but you
can find the time to be productive that
way it doesn't mean you know you
abandon your family and all that stuff
i'm talking about the intensity
of your focus and so i wanted to get
that out i really i really felt that you
know
answering i've got so many questions
along the same line that
that's basically the way i feel about it
it's it's not
it's not something that you immediately
find
intuitive but you will find over time
that these attributes matter so let's
summarize
prioritization putting that list
together writing it down really works
looking good feeling good taking care of
yourself no question about it
you know being extremely focused on your
own discipline is great but have
other passions watch collecting love
that
i've talked about music all that stuff
you got to do all that you have to find
that ying and yang
and all of a sudden you'll find a new
energy that comes up
if you try and follow these disciplines
life's really interesting that way
you're always learning from it take care
my friends till next time
[Music]
you